l'importation porte plainte
cet arsenal de la préfecture ont été
inculpés il se retourne contre qui à
leur tour sont incultes et de
dénonciation calomnieuse et nous sommes
à ce moment là la première l'instruction
est suspendu aujourd'hui la chancellerie
demandent une nouvelle expertise 1983
maurice papon est inculpé pour crimes
contre l'humanité d'avoir participé à la
déportation de 1598 après une émulation
la chancellerie par la voix du procureur
général avec la nouvelle il faut savoir
produire
problème central humaine n'est pas
seulement l'affairé petit moment qu'ils
sont encore une certaine département
parties civiles réunies d'une conférence
de presse présentable en donner comme ça
historique d'aujourd'hui 944 aujourd'hui